I think with a certain segment of the
population there were there were polls
taken last few years and in terms of
trust of corporate media Outlets just
like the New York Times and with
Independence and Republicans the number
has like collapsed and once you lose
trust it's really hard to regain it
someone's cheated on their spouse you're
never going to look at them the same way
again because you're always that person
has always been a cheater even if they
have learned their lesson are you really
ever going to be sure and when you have
these organizations that just have
constant propaganda so on and so forth
but with the Democrats they actually
trust in corporate media has actually
increased over the last few years
foreign
we're at the local Studio here in Miami
and I am glad to be with my good friend
Michael malis who has written a book
very apropos my friend the white pill
which I believe is all about Betty White
who played of course Rose nylon on The
Golden Girls in Miami so Betty White
it's your feeling it's actually more of
the case for white nationalism
did you ever see when she was I was only
able to thumb through it so far I could
it was half the white nationalist half
Betty White it's a very odd combination
but I get you there at the end you got
to start back in uh um Saint Olaf so so
I kid you not I mean when I first saw
the cover Whenever You released it maybe
six months ago as a tease or whatever I
see this cover the book is absolutely
beautiful by the way and I want to talk
about the publishing part of it but I
see this cover the white pill and
there's this sort of sitcomy the font
you guys to use reminds me of like a 70s
sitcom kind of thing and I'm looking at
these women here and then Betty White
I'm thinking this is a whole I honestly
thought for a moment it's a whole book
about this well it actually so can we
just talk about The Golden Girls which I
know you're you're almost an expert at
the level that I am I think I'm more of
an expert you might be more yeah I think
if we had a Golden Girls trivia
competition I think I would wipe the
floor with you you have some of their
clothes don't you you wear blanches
negligation I have Margaret Thatcher's
dress yeah and I'm serious yeah and I
have to her bookcases in my house which
as an immigrant is such a sign of like
I've arrived uh and let me tell you like
do you do not want to know how much
costs to get to 10 for 12 bookcases from
London to Austin it's a lot more
expensive than the actual bookcases
themselves yeah well I want to talk
about Austin too because you have fled
New York yes you were you were a big
time New Yorker you were a Brooklyn guy
you did not want to leave but you did
but hold on First with the book yes uh
just some technical stuff so you you
self-publish this right this is a
self-published book but a hardcover
released on Amazon it's blowing up yes
you're taking out Mike Pence yeah I'm
like January 6th dial according to no no
I'm actually doing it for real yeah
um oh that was good the I am delighted
that we are at a point in time when you
and I were kids yeah and people
listening this when they were kids if
you put out your own book your crackpot
and in fact yeah you're complete nothing
yeah right in fact I have a little hobby
sometimes I'll get these old
self-published books from like 60s 70s
and you read them and you think there's
gonna be some nuggets in there and it's
really really bad
um I have one book I just bought called
Belial the rebel Angel there's no
references to it online and it's the guy
who meets this angel in prison and tells
him about thanks to quantum physics all
races are the same it's just I'm making
it sound much more interesting than it
is but the fact that I can be
competitive with you know Mike Pence
Obama uh all these other major household
names when I'm nowhere near their level
in terms of name recognition just speaks
to how much publishing has changed in
recent years and that in and of itself
is a white pill because for over a
century if you want to get again white
pill white pill but see what you did
there you said the title of the book in
a sense no but I mean I'm speaking to
the what the white pill is is an
expression of hope so for a century uh
you had if you want you couldn't have
the show 20 years ago I mean maybe you
could have it on PBS maybe you could
have it on you know like Fox maybe let's
say 30 years ago but in terms of
publishing you've got a handful of major
Publishers which are shrinking they're
trying to buy each other out all the
time and if you don't get a book through
one of those you know all these other
outlets pretend you don't exist now that
is still the case the New York Times
will pretend I don't exist and political
pretend I don't exist sure but in terms
of me reaching an audience and telling a
message not only do I not have to go
through a gatekeeper I also have to
waste the year of my life because as you
know if you get a book deal today on
like January 1st 2023 it's probably
going to come out January 1st 2025 at
the earliest whereas with me I had it
done on a Monday and you know to have it
out you know within a week or two so
that was one of the things that I could
not believe when I you know I did two
books and I could not believe you're I
was like wait a minute if I write these
things in a couple months the first one
I wrote basically in three months I was
like I still have to wait a year yeah
and then suddenly when they're after
that delay it's like well I've moved on
from some of those ideas at this point
you know I try to write something
Timeless but like things do move forward
and you're like man this is archaic yeah
and Publishers complain that like you
know we're consolidating and we're
losing cloud and what are we going to do
about this but there's not even a
hypothetical mechanism for them to turn
the ship around and that's a great thing
a similarly in journalism wouldn't it be
a wonderful thing if the New York Times
wasn't the New York times if the New
York Times was not in that position to
be the officiant and the dictator of you
know public opinion for a large swath of
the population I think it certainly
would be yeah do you think it's fair to
say that it's not anymore I mean I think
something does feel like it's changing
it's been changing for a long time but I
almost think we're on the other side
where it's like if you were sitting next
to somebody at a bar and they were
reading the New York Times if that's
still a thing that people do is that a
thing that people do probably or at a
coffee shop if you're at a coffee shop
and somebody's reading the New York
Times I would be looking at them like
man that is a that is an ill-informed
confused person like I think that has
now sort of gained more momentum than
the person reading the time or you would
think of this person is posturing they
want you to see yes yes that I'm sitting
here yes yeah yeah so I think with a
certain segment of the population there
were there were polls taken last few
years and in terms of trust of corporate
media Outlets just like the New York
Times and with Independence and
Republicans the number has like
collapsed and once you use trust it's
really hard to regain it someone's
cheated on their spouse you're never
going to look at them the same way again
because you're always that person has
always been a cheater even if they have
learned their lesson are you really ever
going to be sure and when you have these
organizations that just have constant
propaganda so on and so forth but with
the Democrats they actually trust in
corporate media has actually increased
over the last few years right yes so
we're seeing this bifurcation but if the
New York Times wants to be the official
house organ as you would put it the left
that's fine you know people have much
more of an issue with CNN or at least
CNN until the recent heads were rolling
then they had been with MSNBC yes Mada
was was a leftist Chris Hayes was a
leftist they have their Leicester point
of view go nuts speaker left his point
of view fox has their right wing point
of view Tucker go nuts you know Sean
handy we know Sean is going to say CNN
like the New York Times has this air of
objectivity and neutrality but when push
comes to shove they will always fall
inside of hard left and I think that
disingenuousness is what the issue
people have with both the times and
formerly CNN they're decreasingly so so
it's kind of a beautiful thing across
Industries right now because not only
are you able to get this out
independently and it's selling
incredibly well that you were telling me
right before we started I mean basically
because it's hardcover they can't even
catch up with the princess yet which is
I tried to buy an extra copy this
morning it was literally two weeks yeah
until you could even get it so it's
doing really well we happen to be
sitting in a studio of a tech company
that I started that you're huge on
Michael's malice.locals.com we've
started to actually build the things I
think there was this idea for the last
couple years that you know Republicans
conservatives anyone on the right
whatever hell we all are at this point
uh we were just going to complain about
everything but it does seem like it's
turning there were two models for this
right so back in the in the late 70s I
believe it was early 80s Roger Ailes was
trying to start Fox and they wanted him
to be like okay we want you to be
competitive with CNN and he goes I want
to beat but the other model was for long
time people I remember this in the early
2000s people were like we need to have a
conservative Daily Show and I don't
think locals is the right-wing version
of anything it's not trying to parallel
something that left unsuccessfully so I
think the way to succeed and I don't
think this is necessarily the right
versus left is do you want to ape uh you
want to be like how I met your father or
do you want to do something that's
original that you can't get elsewhere
and by doing it in that way I think that
creates new audiences and when you have
freshness and Innovation that's an
apolitical thing and historically that
has been a function of leftism leftism
is very highly correlated with
Innovation with Artistry and it's only
in recent years that you have the
organizations that can in some sense be
identified as conservative or right in
whatever you want to call it that have
been creating things that are original
or you know modeling culture is is that
the craziest cultural shift do you think
we've had that it because the lefties
were supposed to be the creative ones
that's generally how it always was the
openness right the conscientiousness
you're going to create great music and
art and stuff like that now they've
become the dogmatic ones and you have
suddenly conservatives
creating things this is this is like a
massive psychological shift I don't
think in modern history meaning let's
say post-civil War has there ever been
red states that are the centers of
culture right in our childhood right it
would be Boston yeah which is now kind
of not a thing Chicago was Major when we
were kids now it's not a thing at all in
terms of creating culture and great food
and so on and so forth but it's not what
Chicago was what Oprah and Phil Donahue
were there right in New York and La now
Austin and Miami are both becoming in
their own way cultural hubs I can't
think of Seattle was a cultural Hub in
so in a smaller Way Portland Detroit
um none of these but now to have a red
state where you know Austin is is a blue
City very much so Miami I think has a
republican Governor if I'm not mistaken
uh Republican mayor
um this is historically in America
culture unprecedented if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell